don't be afraid to learn don't be afraid
to take your time the medical space
things go slow it's okay that you go
slow I mean I mean I did some rules that
were you know they weren't that shiny
but but I learned so much and go forward
slowly and and be ready for that
complexity because you know it won't be
quick rewards it won't be fast no it
would be rigorous it would be hard but
in the end the satisfaction will be
amazing so be ready for that welcome to
20 minute leaders just sit back relax
and learn from the leaders of today it's
a journey each one is different unique
inspiring let's get started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctec
thank you very very much for joining me
we're gonna have such a fascinating
conversation and I'm genuinely excited
to understand a little bit better about
the intersection of technology and
medicine
and you know you're you know with a
computer science background in an MBA
today you're with intuitive robotics
ahead of Israel r d Center in sort of
surgical apologies and and and really
this this combination of Technology
Innovation and and Robotics and uh and
and medical I think it's just such an
interesting con it's such an interesting
inflection point especially around the
world of how do you actually get things
to production you know a lot of times
you know we say Hey you know worst case
we you know move fast and break things
and we'll we'll deploy to production
with bugs here it's it's a little bit of
a different world especially when we're
talking about SD EA approvals and actual
people people's Health at stake and so
you know Roy thank you again for joining
me here even before we dive into all of
that I want to take you back to a junior
high school talking a little bit about
drum that's that's where it all started
tell me a little bit about that yeah
yeah well Junior High School you know
would would have thought then and I
would go to computer science I mean I
um I was I'm the first
um you know I finished the trauma in in
the art school in Tel Aviv it's quite a
famous school and I was kind of you know
the first class that finished
um really was very exciting it was fun
um but then I found out you know it's a
hobby it's nice I like doing it but I'd
rather go and study Physics
um or something that started getting
more interested in
um but but the drama State I mean I can
continue to do to use it I think almost
in my every day it helps in work it
helps when you put up a show and a
company day out
um and and it and it you know and I
think it's anything that you do uh helps
you
on your eyes
the reason uh the reason I I'm bringing
this out of this right at the beginning
is because I'm a drama a kid as well
that was my passion growing up and so uh
that's I I resonate a lot with what with
what you're saying in the introduction
to technology for you and
um the introduction to technology for
you with and then the intersection of
medical tell me how did that progress
into that yeah so you know my career was
not kind of a textbook career go to
university get a degree get a junior job
become a developer
let's go and step in Step no didn't
start out like that
um you know I I finished the Army I had
to provide myself went to work actually
worked middle works and construction and
did that for a few years
um and and really tried but but was
really pulled towards computer science
and things that I studied in high school
and really looked for for that first
chance as everyone did and I got the
chance that it was a medical device
company
um famous one called medino an Israeli
success story and
um and that was my my step into the
industry
um and that was also my school
um but but I never left the medical
space since then I just you know it
became a part of me that's a whole of my
career and I'm going forward
um and and you know with that ups and
downs I needed to to take the
opportunity when I got it I did a lot of
different things not always software
development from the start
uh but but eventually I got the chance
and and I built the software development
demon group there and uh
from there
let's talk a little bit about
um you know the the intersection of
technology and medical devices or or
medicine in general
um what what are the really the the the
the core
complexities and core opportunities and
I'll let you decide to start with
whichever one you you you want
now choose let's start with the
opportunities that's more fun
yeah so medicine is so wide right I mean
it's so wide how many different
um you know residencies do you have in
medicine how many different directions
can you come at this space it's so wide
I mean the opportunities are quite
endless so why are there endless
Solutions out there that's where it
meets the complexity I mean that it all
comes down to to the risk right
eventually
um you want to do something that will
help the patient that will save their
life improve their life be a tool for
the physician and and when you do that
you have risks your product
and you know has a failure
um it's not some down time and and some
some uh revenues down the drain it's
it's people's lives
um and that's why you can't you can't do
it in the same way you can't do it in
the same way you have to take into
consideration all risks and you have to
be very very meticulous in your process
and for that we have standards
um which we work by
um and and yes it's a slower process and
it has a lot of barriers
but eventually something that reaches
um the market and works you know in the
hospital in the physician's hands is a
safe is a good is an efficient product
mm-hmm yeah can you look can you give me
a specific example of something you
you've been working on that you know
started from you know okay let's let's
integrate deep technology into this and
and how it actually and and the process
you had to go through in order to reach
the market and see it take place on a
real patient I mean I can only imagine
the the pro you know the journey the one
must go through for that yeah so let's
take you know an example of of an
algorithm
all right well there's a lot of
algorithms that can be developed for for
medicine and and an algorithm is a piece
of software that works on some some
medical imaging
um and and you can actually sometimes
develop it you know pretty fast if you
have enough data
um and you have some good infrastructure
um but then what you need to do is you
have to have a quality system built okay
you can't just have your small algo team
do some some pipelines and get out an
algorithm get some results it's not
enough you need to build a quality
system according to standards you need
to get audited you need to have all that
in place
and once you have that then you have the
process of validating your algorithm and
it's not enough that it just worked on
your training set so what is your
training set made up yeah does it have
enough Hospital sources does it only
cover May Israel or does it have U.S
data or does it have different ages does
it have different disease types all of
this has to be covered
um just to be validated
once you've done that that's fine
now you can go and do some clinical
trials it's not over you've just
validated it but now you need to see it
through the field and clinical trials
you need hospitals to agree you need
investigators
um very it's very very costly
and at the end all this needs to be
submitted to the FDA and that needs to
be approved then you get re-audited and
then you want to upgrade and you want to
improve your algorithm so here you go
again
and
this is why um this is really a long
process sometimes
in in a matter of years
but but at the end when it works when
you get that feedback from Physicians
and I you know I came back just last
week from a few customer visits on sites
who are actually in hospitals in
operating rooms and you're standing
there and you're seeing your product
work you talk to the Physicians it's
just an amazing it's an amazing feedback
I think it's very different from any
other field where you can
hear a voice of customer
that's amazing and you know if we're
looking for a second zoom out and we'll
zoom in soon
is let's zooming out to
you know the different opportunities in
general that Tech has with medicine in
today's in today's world
um you know what where where do you
think we're going to be seeing you know
some really amazing advances over the
next few years when it comes to the
intersection of attack and and medical
um so first of all I think the steps
will be
will be small and be slow and this won't
be just you know these revolutions that
will change everything
but uh but let's take for example uh
intuitive as an as an example the
flagship product this DaVinci robotic
surgery system it's an amazing science
fiction system where the surgeon sits at
a console comfortably with a 3D View and
controls forearms of a robot
um doing surgery
um but this is the base now all of this
is a digital system
we collect the video that the surgeon is
seeing we have all the events we have
every motion and everything that was
done there recorded now that's a
platform to do so much you can give
insights to The Physician you can
Benchmark
um you know Global performance you could
at the physician
review their procedures take them to
conferences sit with the patients the
patients get a completely different
feedback from the procedure when they
can see the video with highlights of
where
special things you know happened
and and I think this is kind of The Next
Step where the systems that are
operating and are safe and are very
effective we'll have this new additional
layer of opportunity just from the data
that's being collected
yeah I like that no so zooming into
you as a head of the r d group here here
in Israel what does that actually entail
I mean the head of the Orange Israel
we're pretty new group
um and so just about two and a half
years ago started out
um this group has been building up and
we are part of the uh digital
Organization for intuitive so we're
involved in developing
um well those digital products that are
attached to that robotic system
those that could enable collection of
the video of the data bringing it up to
the cloud enabling all those analytics
enabling
um external doctors to Proctor into the
or during the procedure talk to the
operating physician
and then also automate all of the flow
within the or making it easier for the
team
saving them time
saving the mistakes all around that so
so that's part of what that's part of
what we're doing and we're focusing on
on in Israel's side
and you as a leader of the site what is
sort of your your vision
you know leading the you know from from
a leadership perspective
and you know on the on the r d group
so I think you know my my vision is
really building a team that can that can
be a leader in this in this amazing
company we're working with other teams
but we really want to be those better
taking lead uh you know doing The
Cutting Edge
um products and and and we're getting
there we're building up uh we also have
research teams that are working on more
advanced uh algorithmic Solutions and um
and I'm really trying to build up this
team to be
to be a substantial you know having a
substantial impact on the company's
products which we still need to prove
and being a part of a much larger
organization and New York Stock Exchange
company what what is that what does that
mean so intuitive is it's this is in a
U.S corporate yeah 11 000 employees
worldwide it's very large it's huge and
yet
it really kind of has still has that
that kind of smaller company feel I mean
the CEO is is a is an engineer is one of
the first employees of the company
wow okay that the chief digital officer
is someone that wrote code
um inside those robotic systems when
they started out so when you're talking
to these people it doesn't feel like
you're talking to a CEO of a of a large
corporate that doesn't really
exactly know he'll ask you questions
that you
'd be hard to answer but it's it's
really fun and and the people are
amazing
very very talented
um
very very good atmosphere and really a
great company to be in so one
opportunities are is it is this
presenting you know being able to lead a
group within a larger organization I
mean not a lot of people will talk about
perhaps the the different challenges
that it may present you know with large
corporate versus a small startup you've
had you've had the chance to experience
both in your career with Max with Max
qai and and medinal well what are you
now with you know by being a part of
this large company what what
opportunities does this present to you
as an r d leader as you're you know
trying out different things your access
to the right people you know what what
are the things that you are you're
saying are really meaningful yeah it
opens up so much I mean when you're
working in a startup you you know you
have your people it's not a large group
you have the knowledge that they bring
and you always try to get more you try
to meet other people other startups
maybe meet with some larger companies
um you don't probably know that from
your startup so here you know these
people are right there
I mean you have groups who have
vast experience they have connections
within hospitals I mean for this site
visit you know we just had to contact
all those
um uh commercial sales reps and are
right there in the hospital and they
know the Physicians and they know
everyone they can just take you through
that and and that's something amazing
that is very hard to reach when you're a
startup
but then again we still have these small
development groups we're not a huge
organization we can develop and move
fast but we have all of this corporate
infrastructure that really gives you
access to
things that as a startup you sometimes
only dream of
what is your personal vision for your
own contribution
through your work you know if you're
looking at the different things that you
get to be part of what is what is your
what is what is your own vision for your
work here
so I don't want my passion you know we
started with a with a passion around the
medical device and what it does and it
the impact of the products um and then
the technology but I think like really
basic passion is really about people
it's really my vision is you know to
take these you know young leaders that
are now putting up these teams and
really growing them really building up
the the people that we have
um to become you know just better
professionals with that Global reach of
the company and
for me that's you know that's that's
what gives me satisfaction
sorry I want these people to be
yeah and
you know if you're in the show really
it's it's then it's about
you know asking you know why do you do
what you do and I think from from the
context here I am I'm definitely hearing
a lot of the potential of the of of the
the magnitude of impact that you can
create through this type of work if
you're zooming into the the the
day-to-day life that you have as a
leader as an engineer as an innovator
what really gets you going you know what
really are sort of the highlights of
your work
so I think you know I think it's really
part of it is is is those connections
with the larger corporate this visual
it's it's it's new to me and it's it's
very special and intuitive it takes a
lot of you know hard work maybe late
late time calls
uh but when you manage to see
um something connect between teams
Around the Globe coming together and you
know a solution
um coming to life that four or five
teams in completely different locations
are working together on
you know that that's for me is the
highlight of the end it's very difficult
to get there sometime
or is it the fact that they're that
they're you know dispersed and they're
working together the fact that there's a
multi multitude of people working
together what really is the Highlight
there
yeah the fact that we can bring you know
so many different people diverse people
because you know you're saying us and
Americans but it's very diverse there
are people from completely different
backgrounds
um you know bringing them to work as one
team that's
and and seeing that work you know that
that's for me is a highlight
nice and so
other young entrepreneurs looking to get
into Tech and medical space or maybe
they are there well what what have you
learned over your years here that that
you would pass forward as sort of your
own wisdom to other entrepreneurs in the
space and looking to build great
products with you know this uh you know
in this type of domain yeah
so first of all you know don't be afraid
to learn don't be afraid to take your
time the medical space things go slow
it's okay that you go slow I mean I mean
I did some rules that were you know they
weren't that shiny but but I learned so
much
don't be afraid to take that time you
know learn from
from the bottom
um and and and go forward slowly and and
be ready for that complexity because you
know it won't be quick rewards it won't
be fast no it would be rigorous it would
be hard but in the end the satisfaction
will be amazing so be ready for that
um be prepared and
and it can be done
I love it Roy thank you so much for your
time and for your uh for your energy I
really appreciate it best of luck with
with everything that you're doing and
make us proud here with the amazing good
that you're leading and I and uh and
thank you again for sharing with me
thank you it was a pleasure thanks a lot
thank you
[Music]